myths are all well and good until you
expect somebody to live up to them so
[Applause]
[Music]
this is an odd topic and I'm not not too
sure we'll be able to articulate what it
is that's on my mind but let me start
with why I'm talking about this so after
having put it off for a while because of
the very mixed reception it initially
got I have now finally seen the film the
Grady show the Hugh Jackman musical
movie about PT Barnum and the there was
a lot going on in terms of you know the
the praise and the criticism of it so
just to briefly before I get into my
main topic I will say I enjoyed the
movie actually quite a bit it was a lot
of fun I enjoyed the soundtrack I think
it's one of the better movie musicals in
a while and I mean that very
specifically in terms of wording in so
far as it's been a long time since I've
seen a musical that takes as much
advantage of the fact that it is a movie
as this there are plenty of musicals out
there that I enjoy as movies but
ultimately they do very little to
differentiate themselves with what will
be done with that exact same thing on a
stage whereas this I thought took
incredibly good advantage of the visual
medium plus I liked the songs so sue me
but the thing was the the main sort of I
mean you know there were people who just
you know didn't like it or did like it
but sort of what became the lightning
rod for that film was the issue of PT
Barnum himself so the film very much
feeds into the myth of PT Barnum and the
myth of PT Barnum especially as the film
presents it is a man who built himself
up from nothing with a desire to bring
joy and
happiness to as many people as he could
and who gave a meaningful and empowering
outlet to a great deal of downtrodden
people who were his his performers
that's the film the reality of PT Barnum
is without going into a ton of detail
let's just go with much more complicated
than that and there's a lot of argument
to be had about to what degree was there
any philanthropy and what he was doing
and to what degree was he simply taking
advantage of his performers and you know
there's there's arguments to be made all
over the place but it certainly is the
reality at the very least is not the
clean-cut story that the film presented
and that seemed to rub a lot of people
the wrong way that that this film was
taking someone who a lot of people feel
is not someone to be admired and
presenting an empowering story built
around him and his life in his pursuits
and they a fair number of people
basically took a fundamental objection
to that and while I had while I did
enjoy the movie I can't say that
anybody's wrong for feeling that way
because yeah that is what we did and
that gets me into what I want to talk
about in general which is myth making
modern-day myth making now when people
you know talk about oh the modern-day
mythology you know they'll mention like
superheroes or whatever and that's not
really what I'm talking about
I'm talking about the ways in which we
as a society through our entertainment
our history classes just the way we
discuss things take figures who were
real people and build up the myth of
them in a way that is that is either
disregarding or very selective of the
reality of them and it's an interesting
thing that goes on and I find my
self sort of going through this whole
thing in my head and and we'll see if I
if I can bring it out in any way that
makes sense
so one of the things about mythology at
all I mean you know you go way back much
of mythology was built around you know
trying to explain the world certainly
your creation myths and anything like
that but you know a big part of
mythology also were tales of heroes
you know Greek mythology you had
Hercules Egyptian mythology you had
figures like Osiris and you know yet
things that were contributing to you
know building a myth of how the world
functions but there were just stories of
you know mythical figures who did great
things and funnily enough you go back to
a lot of those myths and the characters
actually aren't as heroic as our modern
day standards but it presents you some
with someone to aspire to in some ways
that someone who exemplifies some great
element a great ability of strength a
great sense of justice you know
something great about them and I do
think having points of reference for
that is important like for just reciting
for a society and for us as individuals
growing up to have that just just grab
on to you know our myths they actually
matter they are actually important
because we can our myths allow us to
create the ideals and that's more sort
of more modern myth making because like
I said classical myths those characters
who sometimes especially like really
look into Hercules one of these days
yeah not a nice guy but as we've gotten
more into modern times myths tended to
be much more about embracing the ideal
embracing you know true heroism purity
can
fiction and things of that nature those
became our myths but as we came to be
able to explain more of the world and
how it functioned we moved away from the
fantastical myths because you know they
we knew that that wasn't how the world
worked so you you didn't really get new
Herculean type stories you know you had
that you had the Arthurian legend but
then as you got into you know something
like the Renaissance and then forward
from there you know we started to build
our myths around people real people not
you know people of very dubious
historical merit which Arthur kind of is
Robin Hood certainly is or who likely
never existed at all like Hercules or a
lot of those sort of classic myths but
you know taking real people who we knew
real facts about the building myths
around them so coming forward into the
modern age some of the figures that we
have built myths around obviously I
mentioned the greatest showman so PT
Barnum is a nice recent example we can
almost sort of see modern myth-making in
real time with that film but some other
things to talk about Columbus a lot of
myth-making around that guy in terms of
what his trip to the Americas and where
he landed what it meant what he was
trying to do what he did once he got
here awful lot of myths milk milky
myth-making built up around that and to
the point that trying to inject the
nuance back in that got stripped out of
it and have so many especially young big
historical events the first
the pilgrims the first Thanksgiving
people like Abraham Lincoln you know who
did great things many of these these
people we make myths out of they did do
great things but we mythologize them and
we idolize them but they were people and
if people are flawed that we have to be
there is no such thing as a perfect
human being with the possible exception
of Fred Rogers like the world does not
produce perfect people it just create it
just produces people and sometimes
people do great things but they're still
flawed where I think modern myth-making
gets us in trouble is we get we get
invested in our myths because we put
stock of ourselves into them we place a
value our values into the people that we
have built our myths around and so when
those myths then get challenged by facts
or at the very least with the full
context to that mythologizing test or
remove we get oddly resistant and oddly
defensive about it you know why you got
to ruin this thing or you know insisting
that you know well no that's not true or
that's not what's important or
what-have-you and we get really weird
sometimes
like yeah as people as a society when
our the myths that we favor get attacked
because we have attributed a certain
degree our values in to some of these
myths
then when the myth gets attacked we feel
attacked and not I I don't want to get
overly political with this but I do
think this does lean into politics a
little bit so like one of the big issues
in
America well yeah I say big there's a
lot of big issues one of the persistent
recent issues have been depictions of
heroes of the Confederacy from the Civil
War because in certain parts of the
country there are statues of Confederate
war heroes and there are places that
still fly the Confederate flag and
without trying to rehash and like go
through that whole debate because
there's a lot going on there's a lot to
unpack but I do think part of the
problem is that those figures have been
mythologized in some of these areas and
that makes it much more painful when
somebody says you know we really
shouldn't be celebrating these people
because if you've been raised and taught
and sort of living in this area and the
society in this part of the country that
has been mythologizing these people for
their tactical prowess for their defense
of their homes for their commitment to
their feather fellow soldiers and
brotherhood you know if you've been
idolizing them for that being told well
yeah but they fought to retain the right
to own slaves we really shouldn't be
celebrating that you end up taking that
more personally then it's probably
intended to be it especially gets tricky
down in the south where you have people
who have who know like that they know
they know their own family tree well
enough to know that they had relatives
who fought in the Civil War and you know
when you look at your own family history
we all have a tendency to even if we
don't even if we haven't had like
specific stories passed down we tend to
want to mythologize our own history as
much as we possibly can and that
includes the the history of the people
on our family line who came before us ie
it's it became a recurring thing would I
forget what the show was but there was
there was I think was a PBS show that
basically did genealogy for celebrities
and
became a sticking point for a number of
them whether or not they had people who
owned slaves and their history and the
thing was odds are Moe's a good chunk of
them did whether they lived whether
their family was from the south or the
north
odds are sooner or later that was gonna
turn up it was a good shot at it
and that's not an easy thing to hear no
matter who you are because you you want
to believe that you are good and part of
that for many of us believes you want
you want to believe that you come from
good stock and good people and to have
that myth attacked feels like an attack
on you I think in many ways we live
right now in the age of personal myth
making not by design but just by where
things are because you'd think about
what social media is the way you curate
what of yourself you put out on social
media which thoughts you share which
pictures you share in my case which
videos I put out I'm I'm building a myth
of me I'm selecting what parts of myself
that I put forward in video form for
people to look at and get a picture get
a myth of Who I am because ultimately
it's impossible to know every detail of
any person so but the more that you know
about someone the more context that you
can have yeah the more the myth breaks
down to pull it back to media and
entertainment cuz media is a big part of
mythologizing of real life people
whenever there is a story that is beta
know based on a true story even if it's
something as exaggerated as the greatest
showmen you know that which is obviously
it's a musical it's very heightened like
this is obviously not
you know a a documentary I mean clearly
that's always an argument with a piece
of ended look it's not a documentary
well there's few cases where that could
be more obvious than by making it a big
bombastic musical clearly this is not a
documentary and yet at the same time if
it is successful that solidifies the
popular understanding of who PT Barnum
was that solidifies his myth and that's
kind of what happens when you have
stories based on reality so when you
have something like you know a film like
Lincoln
that's that solidifies what is the myth
of Lincoln in our society and even more
modern-day you know it doesn't always
have to be deceased people you know you
can have things like the blindside you
know solidity or I mean I he was
deceased by the time it came out but you
know he wasn't when they started making
it American sniper was very much about
the myth of Chris Kyle and what always
comes up in these things is the
inaccuracies because the sacrifices that
honestly we have to make in order to
have an entertaining film because life
is and a person's life is messy is not
clean is not a smooth narrative but if
you're gonna make a film you kind of
need one even if you're not gonna like
sugarcoat it and make sure there's a
happy ending you still got a format so
there's a beginning middle end and
there's a through line some people don't
have a clear through line to their lives
I'd argue most of us don't but you still
need one so you pick and you choose and
you create a mythology so what's the
answer because I don't think the answer
is to necessarily you know avoid myth
maze like I said I think myths have
value I think where we put our stock
where we take our inspiration from we
need something to take it from
you know we do need that so I have to
wonder with something like the greatest
showman would it have been better if it
was very clue clearly inspired by PT
Barnum and it was a PT Barnum s
character but that it but they gave him
a different name they made him an
original character taking influence from
Barnum and he and his life in his circus
and all that but not say not having him
be hi I'm Petey Warren in the movie
would that have been better in terms of
mythologizing in terms of the concerns
of people who look at and go we should
not be you know assigning to this guy
that you know this image of this hero of
the downtrodden maybe maybe just
changing and having it not be you know
the real guy maybe that would help but
at the same time I don't know because I
think there's a potential damage if all
of our heroes if all of the myths that
we look up to are all distinctly
fictional so like I do think there is a
value in calling superhero stories the
modern-day mythology we have built these
superheroes into mythological level
figures and to be you know exemplars of
some thing that we deem to be a value
you know exemplars of a sense of justice
Captain America exemplars of
intelligence with Tony Stark exemplars
of strength applied with compassion with
Superman you know we have all these I do
think that there is there is value there
but if all of our myths were not we're
not in some way tied to real people
do we make the ideals to distance wood
the wood a world in which we only ever
are completely blunt and flat and don't
mythologize real people and we have our
ideals always be in fiction is that a
world where those ideals seem less
attainable because well there's no real
person that I can look up to because
they're all these flawed messy people
who sometimes get some aspects of their
life and their pursuits right but you
know you can't idolize that and I
suppose the question is is the
idolization of a real person more
damaging than not having a real person
to ground an ideology in IE
not believing that real people can hold
ideals and live up to them I don't know
III really don't that like I said this
is something about I'm going back and
forth on and it's just mulling it over
in my head because it it was a funny
thing and it was part of why I resisted
seeing the greatest showmen for a while
because I knew about that aspect of it
that it mythologize is a flawed
controversial figure and yet it's a film
that I liked my daughter liked she loved
the song this is me which is you know
absolutely a I refuse to be ashamed of
Who I am and I refuse to be ignored and
it's a wonderful it's a great song it's
a terrific message and I'm glad she has
that yeah at the same time she has it in
a story tied to this man who is not what
the film presented him to be it's a mix
everything we do is a mix I much like
our hero our
people cannot be the ideal of their myth
the entertainment that we produce and
that we take in also can't be perfect it
never will be which is an odd thing for
someone like me to point out who tends
to nitpick and and I try not to over
focus in zero in on flaws but I'm rarely
one to gloss over them it can seem like
I'm looking for perfection and I'm not
because I don't think it exists I don't
think it exists in people I don't think
it exists in art I don't I don't believe
there is such a thing but that doesn't
mean that I don't believe that my
pointing out flaws or issues in
something means that therefore it's
worthless if we don't acknowledge the
flaws of something well that's now we're
just blinding ourselves like there are
you know my favorite movies are not
flawless movies they've got issues
because everything has issues
every person has issues and yet that is
such a existential quandary to live in
all the time like everything is flawed
that that that is a that is a path it
can be a rabbit hole that you can really
tumble down emotionally and
existentially depending on you know the
kind of person you are and just how your
brain works so for that reason I think
again there is there is a value in
seeing only the beauty in something
seeing only the best of the myth and yet
that can also be damaging I think I'll
wrap up there because I don't have like
I can't have a greater point that I'm
building to because I can't come down on
a firm answer for this and at this point
I think I would just keep reiterating
the same thing I've said for the last
few minutes so I'll wrap up there this
was a weird one because for some reason
I wanted to talk this out but I think
this is probably the most weirdly
abstract and philosophical I've gotten
on here I have no idea if anyone
even gonna stick all the way through
this because this is turned out to be a
weird one but if you did thank you
power to you if you stuck wit me through
this
yeah whatever your thoughts are on
anything that I have just gone on about
if it even made sense drop something
down in the comments let's talk about it
um there's also you know links and
buttons and a whole bunch of things and
like they take you places and they do
things beyond down there so go ahead and
check those out if you want to otherwise
folks it just leaves me to remind you
that you're the council I just run the
meetings and until next time this
council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]